if you could answer
or acquire the answer to any one mystery
what mystery would it be there are many
mysteries i'd like to solve
some on an intellectual level
some on a human level so let me just
mention
two i'm sure i could think of many more
on an intellectual level
i would very much like to solve the
problem that i called galileo's
challenge
how and descartes challenged how
are these miracles possible
we haven't the slightest idea
we can understand the mechanisms
that enter into these
uh actions free creative use of language
have the slightest idea how it's
exercised i think that's true of
voluntary emotion generally the
leading scientists who study the
neuroscience of voluntary motion
i don't mean complicated things like
speaking but
simple things like say raising your
finger
and trying to decide what goes on when
you decide to raise your fingers
you have no idea what they say
the two leading scientists uh
actually former colleagues of mine at
mit when i was at mit
uh medio beaczy uh
robert of jamie and they wrote a
state-of-the-art paper not long ago in
which
they put it as they say rather
fancifully
that we can understand we're coming to
understand
the puppet and the strings but we have
nothing to say
about the puppeteer and it's a very
mysterious fact
because even for the most simple actions
like this
why not there's experimental evidence
showing
that the decision to raise
your finger is made about
half a second before you become
conscious of deciding it
so the decision is made preconsciously
in ways which you have no understanding
of it at a
much richer level it becomes the
question of how
you and i are doing what we're doing
right now
how can we constantly be engaging in
this process of
creating new structures new thoughts
maybe new in the history of the language
others understand them instantly
and can somehow penetrate
to our minds even though they have no
access to our minds
just through the use of a few symbols
all of that is highly mysterious i know
i'm never gonna solve it in fact humans
may never solve it
maybe beyond human capacity but it would
be
an amazing discovery now turning to the
human level
there is an astonishing problem that
we're facing
right now an overwhelming problem
for the first time in the history
of the human species we have to decide
quickly whether the human experiment
will
continue or whether it's soon
gonna end in an inglorious catastrophe
now there are two major problems issues
one of them is heating the planet
if it goes on on the present course
we will soon be at a level where
human survival is impossible that's
not seriously in doubt we know
how to and the same is true of nuclear
weapons
the threat of the use of nuclear weapons
is sharply increasing
of chances of surviving that are very
slight
in both cases and in fact in every other
case of a major
problem we have answers
there are feasible solutions
they're right on the table and spill
them out
perfectly feasible solutions we have a
brief period
in which we can grasp the opportunity
and solve the problems
now here comes the question humans are
not
doing it they are racing to disaster
that's kind of like what i said about
the vaccines
by monopolizing the vaccines
malaria is criminal ethically but it's
suicidal
these are things that we all we know we
know
we're engaged in suicidal activity we
know that there are answers here they
are
but we can't act on the answers now the
question is
can humans develop the will
and the moral and intellectual
capacities
which will enable them to save
the species from essential destruction
in the not distant future if that
question isn't answered
nothing else matters